it's like it's about that time I'll get
started my name is Eric Dominic this is
hack the derivative I'm a software
engineer at a company called game trader
media we were in New York but I grew up
in Seattle so I'm really happy to be
able to come back and present here we're
hiring so if anybody is interested you
can check out that link so let's get
started it's just quick outline before
we dive right into it sort of what I'm
going to cover we're just going to start
with like a real quick calculus crash
course in case you don't remember you
know that calc one course back in
college about exactly what the
derivative is then we're going to talk
about the finite difference method for
estimating the derivative and going to
break it and to figure out why it breaks
we're going to look at floating point
arithmetic and the implementation of
floating point numbers and then we're
going to try and do better but before we
do that we need to understand a little
complex analysis and use some imaginary
numbers and then once we've got that
sort of under our belt we're going to
hack the derivative if anybody feels
like they want to follow along or check
it out afterwards there's like six
functions that I use so I put them all
on a Python file and you can pip install
it it's also on github so if you if you
feel like using these functions you
don't have to copy them on the slides
there they're all pip installable so
taking the derivative so we're going to
consider a function f of X and it's
going to map from our on to our it may
not map on the all of our so for example
our first first one here x squared the
result of that's always going to be
positive so it's going to map onto a
subset of our our last example here is
not actually defined at X 0 so it's
actually map from a subset of our to a
subset of our but all these we have all
these functions we can take the
derivative of
now the derivative if we look at sort of
a graph of the function the derivative
is the slope at any given point and so
to see that we sort of like draw a
tangent line that only touches the graph
at a single point and the slope of that
tangent line is the derivative at that
point so unless your function is linear
that slope changes as you move around
the function so those tangent lines
change and so the derivative gives you a
nice way to see what that slope is at
any point so a little more formally if
we want to take the derivative it's the
limit as H goes to zero of f of X plus h
minus f of X over H so essentially if we
go back and look at this where we're
taking two points from the function
drawing a line between them and looking
at that slope and then we're taking the
limit as those points basically become
the same point you want to this limit
needs to exist from both sides in order
for the derivative to exist so for
example we're going to look at x squared
we're going to use x squared quite a bit
through this presentation so just
plugging into the definition of the
derivative we have F prime equal to this
and if you remember your foil operations
you can expand that out and now those X
Squared's subtract from each other and
now we can factor in H out and we get 2x
plus h and the limit of as that goes to
zero is is a pretty simple problem and
we just get 2x and we have the
derivative of x squared so now suppose
we have some function that we want to
find the derivative of at some
particular value we're going to call it
X naught and we don't necessarily want
to do it you know with pen and paper we
want to do it in computer so one
approximation that we can do is called
finite the finite difference method so
that we have this same you know a
definition
and to estimate it we can basically just
plug in an H that's really small and
that's going to be pretty close so we
can implement that in Python very easily
we just you know plug right in and so
here's our x squared function and we can
you know find the derivative at one and
we plug in some small value for H and
you know that's pretty good that's
pretty close so now we have to figure
out well how do we choose the H we
really want the limit is H approaches 0
so probably smaller the better so if we
like hop in and we can actually get the
smallest float that Python can handle
and we said that a equal age and plug
that in oh crap that doesn't work so
well the you know one with the four
zeros in front of it seemed to work
pretty well maybe it'll just work but
sure enough that will break too so if we
try and take the derivative at some very
large number and use that we're going to
get 02 and that's not the right answer
so in order to figure out sort of what's
going on here and and how that's failing
we're going to take a look a closer look
at the floating point numbers so this is
a basic the basic implementation of a
float64 a float 32 is is very similar
but obviously not as much precision or
as many exponent bits well we're just
going to look at 64 so that has one sign
bit so that tells you if the number is
positive or negative 11 exponent bits so
that is basically scaling the floating
point number so that you can get very
small or very large numbers and then 52
bits which are the fraction and so the
way that that's implemented you can look
at either of these these two formulas in
the top one the bees there are our
binary so it's just going to be one
point zero one zero one that's all base
two
then you get two times whatever the
exponent is and so the exponent ranges
from negative 10 23 to positive 10 23 so
you can basically think about this now
it's not exactly but as a big integer 52
bit integer and then some exponent that
sort of tells you like where that scales
to and so because of this you have like
a fixed amount of accuracy and that
means that there are gaps between the
floating-point numbers this isn't true
about the real numbers and so the real
key here is that the gaps change and so
this this image sort of demonstrates
that nicely the gaps near zero are are
quite small because you have a lot of
accuracy there as you get to very large
numbers those gaps are bigger because
the accuracy is relative to like where
you're out in the real numbers and so
this leads to situations where you can
essentially take one floating point
number and add it to another floating
point number and not go anywhere you'll
essentially round off and so I've
written this little fun function called
plus epsilon identity which just
basically says give me an X and some
small value and we're going to add them
together and see if we actually go
anywhere or not so if we set it back
equal to this you know this smallest
float that we have in Python well really
in any floating point implementation if
we're at zero and we add that to it we
do go somewhere it's not the same thing
but however if we're at one and we try
and add that to it we're not going
anywhere and so if we get to some really
big numbers actually we can add a whole
integer to it like you know one to it
and we really don't go anywhere so the
gaps really do get quite big and this
can lead to some problems so the
essential problem here is given wherever
we're at where we're taking the
derivative if we choose an H that's too
small so that we don't really go
anywhere well if we plug that into the
definition that we have the drill
motive f of X plus h is really just f of
X again and we subtract those we get
zero the derivative ends up being zero
and we don't go anywhere and that's not
very fun it's obviously going to lead to
wrong answers unless you happen to be at
a place where the derivative is zero and
it it just kind of magically right on
accident so to to sort of figure this
out we can write a function that will
find us sort of what the base epsilon is
at any given X so this basically just
you know plugs in an epsilon and then
just doubles it until you actually go
somewhere and that gives you a very
close estimate so sort of out how big
the gaps are at the x value that you're
looking at so we can plug that in we can
see okay so what's the gaps at like 1.0
and you know it's 16 or 15 zeros and a2
are you know point and then 15 zeros in
the two and then if we go up to you know
one with ten zeros six zeroes and a one
so you know still pretty small gaps for
for quite a ways but it does you know it
you can see as we go up in order of ten
we lose in order of 10 in this in the
size of our gaps and so if we go up even
really big to like one of the 20 which
is where we we saw it fail earlier the
gaps are like over a thousand which is
pretty big and so that is basically
what's causing our problems when we take
the derivative and so I found these
these lecture notes online I'm actually
curious why I wasn't able to find any
other research around this but this was
a really great proof basically using the
Taylor series to estimate the error that
you get from the floating points
compared to the air you get from using
the finite difference method and they
suggest using an H that's around this
value where you take basically the
square root of EPs at one and then
multiply it by either the absolute value
of x or one so you can check that out
the math seems solid so if we implement
that in our finite difference method we
can now basically just not pass an H
into this function and it will compute
it for you so we can test that out so to
test it out I've written a couple more
functions one just tells me hey what's
what's the error so to test this out we
obviously have to have the function we
need to know what the derivative is so
we just plug those in and subtract them
and that's our the air and then we can
divide that by what the derivative
actually is to get sort of an error rate
and so if we plug in we're going to use
x squared again we know the derivative
is 2x so we get some error rates that
are they're small they're not zero but
but they're you know that's that's
reasonable so what happens if we look at
like sine and cosine so we know that the
cosine is the derivative of sine if you
remember back from calc 1 and so you
know I at one we get a pretty reasonable
error rate but at at one with a with 10
zeros you know one with 20 zeros there's
this pretty bad error rate as bad as it
gets for sine cosine so so that's that's
not good and we can do better but we're
going to have to use some math this is
where it gets fun so we're gonna have to
use some complex analysis how many
people in here have seen this before i
equals yeah swear to negative 1 okay so
good so you know you if you haven't you
may wonder well why do we need this
funny thing so if someone you know tells
you hey go and solve this equation you
know x squared plus 1 equals 0 if you're
limited to the real numbers you're not
going to find a solution for the real
numbers x squared is going to be either
equal to 0 or greater than 0 and if once
you add 1 to it it's always going to be
greater than that 0 you're not going to
find a solution but you plug in I and
you square it you get negative 1 naught
equals 0 so we define this whole new set
numbers called the complex numbers where
it's basically just two real numbers but
you add them together it's X plus iy and
so this basically allows you for any you
know polynomial you'll be able to find
you know for an N degree polynomial be
able to find all n zeros so that's
that's pretty fun so we're going to work
through an example so now we've got F of
Z is Z squared and so we're going to
rewrite Z as X plus iy and so if we plug
that in and carry it all the way through
we can expand that and we end up getting
the I squared becomes negative we get x
squared plus 2i x y minus y squared and
so given any complex function you can
always separate it into its real and
imaginary parts of the function and so
those are usually written as u of x y
and v of x y and so the U of XY is the
real part V of XY is the imaginary part
and so in our example U of XY is just x
squared minus y squared + V of XY is 2xy
note that the eye is not in the V it's
it's when you define the function its I
times V so there's the both of these
functions are actually real valued
functions so now we have you know this
function sort of written as these two
functions and there's four derivatives
that you can take because we have two
functions in each one but two variables
so we can take a partial against both of
them and so if we take you know each of
these partials we get you know 2 X 2 y
negative 2 y 2x there's a nice little
pattern there sort of going diagonally
dudx equals DVD y + D UD y equals
negative DV DX and so these are the
Koshi Riemann equations and they hold
for all analytic functions in C you can
go check your favorite complex analysis
booked for proof if you want i'm going
to leave it to you to you guys for now
unfortunately don't have time to go
through that but this is going to come
in pretty handy so it's time time to do
the hack so we've we have a function
from R to R and we're going to rewrite
it and so now because we are taking this
function of from R to R we can consider
z bar to be some element that's just in
our and so sent it in our if we write it
as X plus iy the y part is going to be 0
because it's it's a real number so X
plus iy if it's real y has to be 0 so we
can now rewatch rewrite f of z bar
equals f of x 0 and then we can separate
that into the two functions just like
above and we have view of x 0 and I
times V of X 0 additionally since we're
mapping onto our we know that the V part
is going to be 0 and so we get F of x0
equals U of X 0 we're trying to take the
derivative of F with respect to X and
for all the Z's that are part of our we
know that F equals you and so the
derivative of F with respect to X is
going to be equal to the derivative of U
with respect to X which we know from the
coaching Riemann equations is going to
be equal to the derivative of V with
respect to Y and so if we go back all
the way to the beginning to the
definition of the derivative and take DV
with respect to Y we can just plug this
in here v of x y plus h minus V of XY /
h and then we know that Y is 0 because
we're taking a Z that's in our and so we
can just plug in y equals 0 here so we
get V of X H minus V of X 0 / 8
we also know that V of X 0 is 0 so we
just get V of X H over H and so to
estimate the derivative we can just take
the function evaluated at x + IH and / H
and so the magic that we've sort of done
here is we've taken something that
normally takes subtraction which is a
very difficult operation for floating
point numbers to do and eliminated that
subtracting and made it just like a
straightforward evaluation of a function
at a single point and then a division
now if you think about the floating
point numbers it's very difficult to do
addition because if two floating point
numbers are of very different accuracy
you're going to get a roundoff error
you're not going to go anywhere like we
showed with that epsilon program problem
but with division because of karma
tivity we can like divide the two digits
that are of accuracy separately than the
exponents and so we don't lose any
accuracy in the division and so we end
up getting far more accurate results so
to implement this in Python in Python
and actually in in most programming
languages the imaginary unit is
represented as a Jay rather than an i
and that's because I is typically used
for County and things like that so you
don't want to like conflict with that or
override it on accent so we just take
the we can take this like min float now
and just use it and then we can take
that step in the imaginary direction and
so if we do that and we set we get our
original functions again and we plug
that in 2.0 and to the right amount of
zeros and two again with the right
amount of zeros so those are exactly
right if you don't believe me we can we
can define these error functions again
and if we go through we have an error
rate of it perfectly zero
so this is pretty awesome so what if we
what if we check it out on the sine and
cosine so the one trick here is that we
have to python has a/c math package
that's for that allows for complex
implementations of functions like sine
cosine the exponential function square
root things like that we need functions
that take complex numbers so sine and
cosine 0.0 0.0 0.0 now this is pretty
good but it's not perfect so we can find
so this is again for sine and cosine if
we take one with five zeros we get a
little bit of an error if we here's a
more complicated derivative function i
just googled like fun derivative
problems so this is x 5x over square
root of x and this i plug this into
Wolfram Alpha to make sure that i did
the math correctly for the derivative
and so that came out so that one at one
point zero you get you know no error but
at you know 10 you get a little bit of
an error i'm at like five point six
seven ID threw something in there you
get a little bit of an air if you go up
to just a hundred or rather a thousand
you get an overflow air and so the the
sea math I think it's the X function
doesn't work very well for for even
relatively small errors so this does
have some pretty stark limitations
around like what can be computed that
doesn't mean that you could write a you
couldn't write a better complex
implementation of of X to get this to
work so a few more limits the function
obviously has to satisfy the Cauchy
Riemann
equations so if you have a function with
like absolute value this isn't going to
work if you have a function with like a
some logic flow in it that uses like a
less than or greater than in it it's not
going to work and obviously all the
assumptions that we made to cancel out
and use the coach agreement equations
assumes that the function is going from
R to R and so if we want to find the
derivative of a complex complex function
at a complex value this this isn't an
appropriate solution this leads to some
interesting questions though these are
some fairly trivial examples absolute
value less than greater than but for a
great majority of functions so you know
if you have an implementation of the
complex numbers it's actually pretty
difficult aside from you know building a
function where you just throw abs in
there to find a function that this isn't
going to work on you know that sort of
gets into some mathematical philosophy
about the nature of functions and
whatnot but by the way that we're able
to sort of codify functions we are lucky
enough to usually have this condition
met so that's that's all I got I've got
plenty of time for for questions you can
check me on the line I've got these
slides up online yeah thanks
yeah so I'm not familiar with the
spectral methods oh sure that's a good
question so sure so if you're using if
you're using a Fourier transform I
believe you would have a complex-valued
function and so sure so the the Fourier
transform is basically going to extract
the frequencies that like out of a
signal so this is slightly different and
you're trying to find like the actual
point derivative at a value maybe if you
worked out the math you this may
actually be going on in the background
I'm so no this isn't this is something
that I I worked on two summers ago
actually in Julia there's a cot there's
a calculus package and I was in hacker
school at the time and worked with a
couple Julia contributors on their
calculus package and discovered this and
was pretty amazed by it and so I've been
sort of researching a little bit more
and putting slides together to talk
about it why not unfortunately I don't
have a lot of opportunities to take the
derivative of arbitrary functions at
work but would be fun any other
questions yeah
find different points and this is if you
already have a definition of the
function value point so once you have a
bunch of sample points you're
essentially using for a transcript bit
of curve through didn't compute
at that one sample point but for all the
samples and that's a completely
different question what this is trying
answer this we have a function they can
evaluated arbitrary precision
if you
any other questions we got plenty of
time all right thanks